hi and first of all I'd like to thank
everyone who's attending this talk
virtually today my name is Stephanie
will earth and I'ma Canada Research
Chair biomedical engineering at the
University Victoria like you can see in
my side I'm jointly appointed in our
departments in mechanical engineering in
our division of medical sciences and
since this is the neuroscience focused
conference I wanted to point out that
our division of medical sciences has
recently in the last few years start
offering a neuroscience grad program in
case there any prospective students out
there who might be interested in working
with us today I'll be talking about how
to engineer reproducible neural tissue
from pluripotent stem cells and try and
describe some of the different types of
scaffolding out there available to help
you deliver cell therapies for different
types of neurological disorders to sort
off since this is the emerging
technology section I wanted to discuss a
little bit out what tissue engineering
is and define it before diving into my
research so Langer of the Conti defined
tissue engineering as using those
biology and engineering to develop
functional substitutes for disease door
damaged tissue and you can see an
example of this here on the slide as an
engineer trachea and usually with
engineered tissues you combine things
like cells with biomaterial scaffolds as
well as chemical cues like growth
factors or small molecules like retinoic
acid in order to replicate the structure
and some types found in those tissues in
healthy tissue and if you want to read
more I actually wrote a book chapter on
this which is available through the
hybrid stem cell institute at Steinbach
org in terms of the bio material
selection you can use the natural
applied materials or synthetic
biomaterials each of them have specific
advantages and disadvantages and i'll be
talking about both of those in my talk
today and depending on your material
choice it's obviously going to influence
how they behave when you plant them in
the body and for those reasons certain
materials may be more desirable for
certain engineering certain tissues as
opposed to others as this is a
neuroscience conference and my specific
areas normal tissue engineering and
today I'll be talking about her we're
trying to engineer tissues to repair
spinal cord in British Columbia we have
several local agencies which are centers
of excellence in terms of developing
treatments for spinal cord injury and
these include the international
collaboration on repair discoveries or I
cord which I'm a member of as well as
the McCanns and Institute and both of
these institutions are quite committed
to trying to find new treatments and
cures for people who are living with
spinal cord injury and then 2010 the
Rick Hansen Institute actually had
commissioned as an extensive survey to
determine how many people in Canada were
actually suffering from such injuries
and they found about 85,000 people do do
suffer currently live with spinal cord
injuries here in Canada with
approximately 4,000 new cases occurring
each year here in DC you really see a
dual population wendys primarily affect
younger males as well as an older
population with typically the younger
population be affected by things like
sporting accidents motor vehicle
accidents with the elderly population it
being more from things like Falls and
and one of the things that came out of
this study was that these injuries
caused a huge deal of a physical and
financial burdens and so that's it's
important to try and develop treatments
for these and in fact currently there's
no available treatment to regenerate the
injured spinal cord most of these
treatments focus on post surgical
intervention or applying things like
steroids or other things to reduce
inflammation after these injuries and
this is one of the reasons lots of
researchers have been looking into
different types of cell therapies for
the treatment of these injuries and in
fact a little bit i'll talk about
jared's clinical trial and the actually
was using a cell therapy and attempt to
have treat these injuries this is just a
slide since we'll be talking about stem
cells and the central nervous system
what sort of cells would we want to make
from our stem cells and then three major
cell types you find in the central
nervous system there are the neurons
your information transmitting units that
allow your brain to signal throughout
your body they're lots of different
types of neurons and I'll get them to
talk a little bit later about what we're
trying to spin or more specifically
trying to make for the treatment of
spinal cord injury there are like a
dangerous sites which I'll also talk
about with the gerund clinical trial
these active insulators and they wrap
around your axons to out them to
efficiently transmit these signals and
then
also the astrocytes of service support
cells which can best provide nutrients
to your neurons and oligodendrocytes
doesn't play an important role or making
up the blood-brain barrier which
protects our central nervous system my
old books with pluripotent stem cells
which and essentially these cells have
two main properties one is they can
self-renew indefinitely so they can make
more pluripotent stem cells the other
properties they can become any Cell tied
found in the body for a while there and
the main type of pluripotent stem cells
that were commonly used in research for
embryonic stem cells Madison Bionic stem
cells were generated first in 1981 with
human cells being produced much later in
1986 he's a drive from the inner cell
mass of the blastocyst and he is the
neuroscience talk were obviously trying
to direct these cells down lineages to
make neurons or oligodendrocytes or
astrocytes recently and they found and
this was in 2006 yamanaka and his
colleagues and some other groups
reported you could reprogram adult cells
using certain factors in order to return
them to these pluripotent states and
this was a huge discovery he won the
Nobel Prize for it in 2012 and so this
sort of provided a way of getting around
the seats of embryos to make your
pluripotent stem cells so a very hot
area of research there's a lot of
scientific groups out there who are
working on this issue's of reprogramming
increasing the efficiency of
reprogramming reducing the time for
reprogramming and so on as a tissue
engineer what was very appealing about
these cells is you could barely take a
person's adult cells reprogram them back
to the stem cell-like state
differentiate them down into specific
lineages and generate patient specific
tissues just highlight some of these key
differences between our embryonic and
induced pluripotent stem cells and
induced pluripotent stem cells
eliminated the need to use embryos to
generate new cell lines especially in
the United States where I did my
training initially this was a very
controversial issue for a while there
your stem cell lines were restricted and
so forth and it provided a way to get
around decease of embryos and seem to be
less ethically controversial as I
mentioned before one of the things I
found very exciting
about these ways you can make patient
specific tissues and patient specific
cell lines and groups in Japan are
actually working on making specifically
IPSC banks for such purposes I know a
lot of neuroscience groups are very
interested in reprogramming adult cells
taken from patients with neurological
diseases things like Parkinson's or
Alzheimer's so they can get these
embryonic stem cell lines and use them
as diseased cell models and that's also
a very interesting right of work
although that's not what we focus on as
these cells have not been around for a
couple years and people started Plan B's
to do in vivo studies one of the things
that has been quite interesting is that
some of these IPSC lines actually show
reduced risk of tumor formation compared
to embryonic stem cells when you
transplant them into animal studies and
this is something that was kind of
surprising to come out in terms of why
you would use once I'll take over the
other and finally and just to highlight
some of the possible differences there's
a lot of work going on characterizing
the differences in gene expression and
epigenetics between these embryonic stem
cells versus our reprogram cells and how
close are they and can you substitute
one for the other in terms of the
nervous system I think this is a really
good area to be working in not just
because we're to neuroscience conference
but because this is where these
therapies are actually going to clinical
trial as I mentioned previously Darren
actually took human embryonic stem cells
and use them to produce oligodendrocytes
for the pair of spinal cord and actually
implanted these into several patients
well they didn't observe any adverse
effects which was I believe the purpose
of their study they did shut down due to
lack of funding although they are
committed to follow their patients
through the course of a study they've
reformed this the cell therapy branch
was spun off and has reformed his bio
time and they're trying to essentially
bring back this clinical trial but it
was groundbreaking in the fact that they
were actually able to get cells derived
from these pluripotent stem cells into
people recently advanced health era p
has been running clinical trials where
they've taken a retinal pigment
epithelium cells and use them to treat
macular degeneration and these are have
been more promising and they're actually
recruiting a lot more members to these
studies so I think these are two really
good examples of you
to actually bridge the gap and take all
the promise that's pluripotent stem
cells have had and actually start to
take them to the clinic so in terms of
induced pluripotent stem cells it's sort
of a similar story along the retinal
pigment epithelial cell story the
Writing Center for developmental biology
and Kobe wants to do something similar
but instead of using the human embryonic
stem cells they use the ipsc technology
and they've received approval for this
trial and they are going to start
running it I believe this year and so
it'll be quite interesting to see how
this compares with some of the human
work that's already been done and and
the equivalency of these these studies
but again just some more evidence that
these these technologies are
translatable and they are going into the
clinic when my group comes in is often
times with these cell studies you're
just directly injecting cells into an
injury site or a lesion and it's not
often a good environment for the cells
to grow in and so we try to provide a
better environment to the use of 3d
scaffolds as well as drug releasing
scaffolds that can help control the
behavior of these cells were
transplanting and so here's some of our
tools we have for engineering our neural
tissue and this is a general overview
slide and i'll be talking about it some
of these specific examples today so as
you can see we have with our embryonic
stem cells and are induced pluripotent
stem cells and my lab actually works
with all works with both Mouse versions
of mouse dses and he ipscs as well as
human es ease and human ipscs as well so
we have all four of those cell lines
going I'll talk about when we get into
our human cells about trying to
standardize the differentiation process
using some micro well differentiation
techniques and just some more pictures
showing what our lab can do in terms of
differentiating ourselves into neural
rosettes and then where we give in to
our tissue engineering we have our
biomaterial scaffolds we commonly use a
3d biomaterial scaffold made from the
protein fibrin we have some drug
releasing microspheres which I won't
talk about today but could potentially
be useful for some other neural tissue
applications as well as the
multifunctional
nano fiber scaffolds and we combined
these different cell types with
different scaffolds depending on what
areas of the nervous system we want to
treat and we can essentially combine
these depending on application and
location as well and one of the nice
things about working with our vibrant
scaffolds is they can be polymerized at
different rates so in theory they could
be inductive all along with our drug the
leasing microspheres before I get into
all of our neural differentiation I
wanted to quickly talk about how stem
cells and pluripotent stem cells
maintain this ploy potency and his
offers talk about some of our studies
done with mouse cells and then I'll talk
about how we actually translate those
two humans and some of the disconnects
we observe and between the two types of
cells so in maintaining play potency
there's a trio of transcription factors
essentially maintain this state and
those are awk for socks too and nanog
and they'll feed back on each other in
order to maintain these high levels of
expression and maintain this ability to
differentiate into any cell type which
is pretty cozy and for those of you who
aren't as familiar with the stencil and
field just to give you idea what the
Yamanaka factors are this factor is
expressed that are overexpressed in
adult cells to reprogram cells those
include opt for socks to see Mick and
klf4 just briefly to review how mouse
cells are maintained to maintain their
pluripotency you'll notice i'll show the
human side version of this slide later
in my talk both of these pathways rely
on these three signaling pathways to
maintain or on wind signaling plays an
important role maintaining pluripotency
in both mouse and human cells but my
motors for the mouse cells to the major
pathways involved with human have
leukemia inhibitory factor or LIF and
bone morphogenic protein for the mp4 and
so these are the two pathways that
really help activate those socks too and
nanog to keep these regulatory circuits
up and maintain pluripotency the reason
I mentioned this is to then we'll start
talking about how a culture mouse and
then how a culture human as humans have
much stricter
quirements than just and what you can
get away with in terms of mouse cells
Sony culture a mouse / codon stem cells
in order to activate these pathways we
actually stopped some into it with live
in order to activate that pluripotency
pathway and we also grow them on feeder
layers consisting of mouse embryonic
fibroblasts like you see here in this
picture and so these mouse embryonic
fibroblast secrete doctors that enable
these cells to maintain their
pluripotency this is also a media
supplemented with serum as well which is
not always used with human cells for
reasons I'll talk about later just where
the chosen representative images for
these studies i'll be talking about our
human or mouse embryonic stem cell line
where r 1 cells which is very standard
mouse embryonic stem cell line we
obtained from the nike lab in toronto we
bought our mouse ipsc line from systems
Biosciences as well and you can see they
form nice colonies and one of the themes
you'll see throughout my talk is that
anytime you're growing these stem cells
they really like to grow as aggregates
both when they're undifferentiated and
during the differentiation process so
now that we have our pluripotent mouse
stem cells how do we actually get them
to go into neural phenotypes it's quite
common in stem cell culture in order to
grow these cells as aggregates in
suspension in order to get them to
differentiate although in the neural
field people are also now moving towards
protocols which to avoid the use of
android body so in their bodies what we
refer to these aggregates of pluripotent
stem cells that form usually when their
culture of non-adhesive plates otherwise
your cells will sit down and start
growing or mimics the differentiation
process and because of that we can treat
them with the chemical cues we find
during differentiation in order to drive
them down the snarl lineage so i have
the work will be talking about today was
we were trying to find a more effective
way to generate neurons with an emphasis
on motor neuron so that we didn't do it
for arm ourselves just yet and by
comparing two different protocols and
essentially this employed body formation
protocol that uses retinoic acid has
been around for quite a while i believe
the original publication is from bein at
all in 98 and you culture your mouse
pluripotent stem cells for eight
is the first four days you allow the
aggregates to form the last four days
you too with right now gasset and well
recently another protocol has come out
where which is much shorter which is six
days and in this case you love
aggregates to form for two days and the
last two days you treat with retinoic
acid and a small molecule called pure
morph amine and pure morphine is
actually a sonic hedgehog agonist so
performs the same old sonic hedgehog but
it's much more affordable than the
protein itself and this is very
consistent with some of the pathways
that pattern motor neurons during
development so now we're working with
our ipscs we wanted to see how similar
they behave to our mouse i FCS and we
were able to generate inboard bodies
this was quite straightforward and this
works a couple years old now but at the
time it was right when people are still
trying to determine what some of the
differences were between mouse cscs and
mouse ipsc so seeing that they behaved
both in culture and would generate
android body is just like our mouse
embryonic stem cells was quite promising
one of the other things we were
concerned with was we knew these
protocols to work quite well with our
mouths esc lines so but they work as
well with her mouth ipsc your lines and
so they did and so this was just showing
that these employed bodies once you made
them and we cultured them they showed
high levels of viability and this is at
the time point for each of them so at
eight days for the 4 minus 4 plus
protocol just right now acid and at six
days for and the protocol with retinoic
acid and pyrimidine we were able to
quantify this viability we use a guava
flow cytometers and you can use an essay
called by account and this will tell you
how many of your cells are viable and
culture and for all of these an action
this is an extended time period and so
the day one is actually the first is at
the end of this protocol either eight
days or six days depending on the
protocol and then the day seven and day
14 will be our extended cultures when
they actually put them inside of our
biomaterial scaffolds but essentially
ourselves maintained a high level
viability throughout this whole process
and all the data I'm going to show which
is quite promising especially as we hope
to someday use these biomaterial
scaffolds in order to as essentially a
scaffold for transplantation
so the 3d scaffolds we see the design
and this will be with the first two
thirds of my talk focus on we use this
biomaterial called fibrin and i'm sure
you've probably heard of this since the
end product of the coagulation cascade
it's a protein that forms with
fibrinogen polymerizes and this is just
a scanning electron microscopy photo of
how it looks we have over wang protein
fibrils you see it a lot surgeons use it
commercially as a surgical sealant and
sells really like to grow in it as I'll
show in a minute and also you can modify
fibrin decane drug delivery systems and
there have been several studies that
have shown that when you transplant stem
cells with fibrin gels into the injured
spinal cord it really dramatically
increases the fraction of cells that
survived and those two studies one is M
by Johnson at all and it was in a soft
matter and this was transplanting Mouse
no progenitors derived from mouse
embryonic stem cells into the injured
spinal cord and then more recent side
that came out and sell from the two
zemski wow they actually I believed use
neural stem cells in combination with
this type of Dell to increase their cell
survival rate so I think it's quite an
appropriate material to be working with
and it's important to see that we can
essentially extend the compatibility of
these scaffolds to be used with and
potentially new opportunities derived
from our induced pluripotent stem cells
to give you an idea of our methods we
essentially were trying to direct
recreate a 3d micro environment in vitro
that would replicate what would happen
if these cells are employed bodies were
being transplanted and in vivo setting
and so in this case we took our inward
bodies we would have polymerize one
layer of our protein gel would add
member body and then polymerize the
second layer on top so these cells were
actually seeing a three-dimensional
protein scaffold we cultured them for
two weeks with immediate change on day
three and we chose two weeks because
this is about how long these scaffolds
lost if you plant them into an injured
rat spinal cord and then at the end of
our study we and as I already showed we
did viability analysis to see how many
of our cells were still alive we also
stained to see what our culture's look
like using immunocytochemistry for the
neuronal marker to you J one
and we also did some so cytometry for
three markers for socks too which is a
ploy potency marker nestin which is an
alpha gender marker and owner in a
marker to UJ 1 so he was just some
pictures showing what these cells look
like after seven days in culture just to
give us a checkpoint and to see that we
were getting no differentiation from all
all of our cell types as some studies
have reported lower neuronal and
differentiation efficiency with mouse
ipscs and so we're seeing some neuronal
staining after seven days in our
culture's inside and this is again is
inside of our 3d gels as you can see you
can go to 14 days you get lots and lots
of neurite extension and you even see
sort of sub embroid bodies forming off
of some of these cultures as well for
both our ipscs as well as our mouse
embryonic stem cell cultures as well so
we're trying to compare both the
protocols as well as differences between
our ipscs and our mouse es-es so we've
been a game using also site telemeter we
were able to stain and quantify the
neuronal differentiation for each of
these cell types and so in this case
what we found is it for all the group's
we saw significantly more neuronal
differentiation after 14 days compared
to seven days which is not unexpected at
all the other thing was that our
protocol that was was shorter but also
involved retinoic acid every more from
you in this t minus 4 plus protocol
pretty significantly more neurons and at
day 14 between both sets of groups so we
solved it both for the mouse is sees his
protocols more efficient at generating
neurons and as well as for the the mouse
embryonic stem cells the other
interesting thing was that he did
generate significantly more neurons when
we used our mouse embryonic stem cells
versus our mouse induced pluripotent
stem cells which based on literature was
not surprising but it was interesting to
confirm using our setting and this was
also the same for the 4 minus 4 plus
protocol as well and so again this just
shows you some of the differences
between the mouse or between the iPSCs
and the hescs
we also stained for the nest and marker
again just to quantify our system and
make sure everything was working
properly and as expected and at most
time points we saw a decrease Ernesto
staining from day 72 day 14 and this
makes sense as the salt continually
differentiate so there should be less
drama genders and more mature cells at
day 14 and again in this case we saw
less neural progenitors when we used the
4 minus 4 plus protocol compared to our
short or 2-4 plus protocol as well but
again this is all consistent with what
we had had expected to see finally and
this is an important consideration is we
wanted to see how many pluripotent stem
cells were left and so we used we stand
for socks too and one of the interesting
things is for the ipscs we did see
significantly more pluripotent cells at
day 7 which we did not observe when we
used the mouse embryonic stem cells and
one of the reasons for this might be
because in our mouse ipscs they do have
socks to being retroviral ii expressed
although this does decrease when we take
them out to 14 days at one concern and
which is always a concern when you're
working with poi cotton stem cells is
that even at day 14 we still had this
population where between eight and ten
percent of the cells we're staining
positive for socks too so that means we
still had this pluripotent stem cell
population hanging around and what that
translates to in vivo usually is the
potential to form tumors and so and this
would suggest possibly if we were going
to move into vivo studies we might need
to sort out these cells before we would
transplant them or try and further
optimize our differentiation protocol to
try and drive this number further down
so so we learned from this was our
neural progenitor is derived from
mouseboy potent stem cells maintained
high levels of viability and 3d
scaffolds and they prefer to be cultured
as aggregates and in terms of viability
we really didn't see any differences
between the iPSCs and the es es and as
we expected longer we cultured them we
saw a decrease in our immature cell
markers but from sorry
see and neural progenitors and an
increase in neuronal marker expression
and I would guess if we look for them we
would also see increases and the all
good into sight markers and astrocyte
markers as well but for this study we've
been mainly trying to focus on neurons
with the goal towards making motor
neurons for transplantation for spinal
cord injury our protocol that used
retinoic acid impure more for me and
increase the percentage of cells the
differentiate into neurons and we're
trying and to translate some of these
protocols for use with our human cells
and the other thing is i mentioned that
about each person these cells express
this pluripotency marker which is always
a concern exok potentially indicates
humor formation and transplantation
studies down the line so and that's
that's sort of the mouse story the next
part I want to move on to is how we
actually take all this stuff we've
learned from our most studies and
translate them into human work and so
one of the big challenges with human
cells is you can't just grow them on
Mousam football you could go to my mouse
and analytics it's not advisable to grow
them in animal products for several
reasons and then how we can actually
make this differentiation process
process more reproducible so we can
actually potentially someday take these
therapies to the clinic and so I'll talk
about and first of all our culture
conditions then how we induce our neural
differentiation and then some of our
bioactive scaffolds that could hopefully
ensure we could replicate these effects
in an in vivo setting so as we move the
mouse to humans one of the things we've
been focusing on for our human studies
is looking at induced pluripotent stem
cells as they seem to be more clinically
relevant source for our transplantation
studies and so that's what I'll show a
lot of our data from for our human work
has been mainly with these human induced
pluripotent stem cells as I mentioned
before human to maintain point potency
of your human cells is quite different
than from your mouse cells and in this
case again you'll see went like I've
talked about before but we also have
fgf2 and active in which these are the
two major pathways you need to hit in
human cells in order for them to
maintain their pluripotency so
originally when people derived human
pluripotent stem cell lines they were
growing on the mouse embryonic feeder
layers like I showed I showed for our
mouse button stem cells however studies
have shown that human cells will
actually take up these mouse proteins or
if you go them in the presence of serum
to also take up these bovine proteins as
well and in theory if you have these ol
define culture systems where you have
variability and where you get your
mouths from variability in your serum
it's going to lead to more variability
in their differentiation potential the
majority people working with human
pluripotent stem cells today are usually
working with a combination of defined
media usually empty zur with major gel
as the coating to grow their cells on
and maitra gel is a mix of extracellular
matrix proteins that are secreted by
mouse cancer cells so again you have
this mouse protein issue that's present
must be dealt with and so in the last
few years a lot of groups have reported
how they can use chemically defined
surfaces with media it's also defined in
order to get away from using these
animal derived products and we in fact
tested some of these products as part of
our collaboration with stem cell
technologies here in Vancouver and part
of that I'm going to show that the
solids we've been using our human cell
line is the h9 cell line which we
obtained those lot of our cell lines
came from my cell it's one of the
classic cell lines and we chose it
because it's been previously shown to
officially differentiate into neural
phenotypes and if you are working with
human embryonic stem cell lines you
should check because certain cell lines
are more efficient at neural
differentiation than others in terms of
our human induced pluripotent stem cell
line we work with and the one dll one
line which is derived from human
foreskin and this was published out of
Thompson's lab in science in 2007 so the
first surface we had began testing in
our collaboration with stem cell
technologies was a product called stem
it here and as you can see it's
essentially e-cat here in protein and
he's activate the FTF GF pathway which
we saw maintains pluripotency and this
is just a shows how these proteins are
mobilized on surfaces the
can then be cultured in the presence of
media like that imp teaser empty sir one
is one of the most commonly used
formulations for human pluripotent stem
cell culture although it does contain
bovine serum albumin it is it is defined
but it does have BSA again Cal proteins
are not always desirable as well as
basic fibroblast growth factor
transforming growth factor-beta and some
other defined substances as well to keep
your cells pluripotent at the time these
technologies were quite new so there are
questions of can we actually thought
cells directly into these media how long
does it take to passage how does it
compare to culturing these cells on
things like maps like maître gel and so
here are just some pictures when we grew
them in defined culture and those are
our human yes season ipscs behaved quite
similarly whenever using these defined
conditions we did some staining just to
see how pluripotent they were and we
found when we in this combination about
forty percent of our human induced
pluripotent stem cells were SS EA for
positive which is a pluripotency marker
expressed by human cells after one
passage so this was quite low so it's a
bit disappointing we also stand for
socks too and we got higher amounts of
socks to staining about sixty-two
percent of our human ipscs were socks to
positive but again these were our IPS CS
and socks to bio expression may have
been influencing causing these counts to
be higher than what it truly could be
while we were working on this project
they actually came out with another
product which was based on the protein
meat renekton which is a glycoprotein
found in serum and so instead of using
the stem adhere you get here in method
and they focused on these glycoproteins
and it's a comedy CM protein and
essentially you coat your surface with
it and grow yourselves on it so we were
then going to try this next in terms of
our defined conditions we also came out
with a reduced a MTG formulation called
teaser 8 which actually got rid of the
BSA and drastically lowered that protein
content so now we're getting towards
more defined systems that we were
previously working with as well so you
essentially repeated all those
but with this media combination so here
we actually saw a really high level of
glory pregnancy so far associate for
positive marker about ninety-eight
percent of ourselves were positive so
these can do much better maintaining
ourselves in a pluripotent state
compared to our other combination of
that stomach here and in teaser one and
again we saw high levels when we looked
at sox2 is about eighty-three percent of
our hph ipscs being positive for this
point pen see mark after passing so this
is the system we've been working with
and we currently use for all of our
cultures because it's defined it has the
reduced protein content and it maintains
really high levels of pluripotency
although I didn't talk about it too much
we actually can thaw and maintain as we
do in our lab outside potent stem cells
and completely defined conditions
previously and stem cell technologies
would recommend if you saw on to either
am F or major gel and then transition
but we've had no problems actually just
flowing directly into these defined
systems and we do find that that are
pluripotent stem cells proliferate
better and maintain high levels of
pluripotency when we culture them on
this feature next feat renekton teaser
e8 media combination so that's that's
I'm talking about however engineering
reproducibility into our pluripotent
culture now I'm going to talk about how
we switch and differentiate ourselves
into our neural progenitors and try and
keep this process uniform and we use
this their technology also from stem
cell technologies which instead relying
on non-adhesive plates they have not
accused of Micra wells to form uniform
Android bodies and so essentially what
you end up getting is a bunch of
aggregates they're all the same size
with approximately the same cell number
so you'll have your egg you up late and
for us again because we're trying to do
neural differentiation we stem cell
technologies proprietary neural
induction media and so when these cells
are being cultured in these Nauticus
applause they're exposed to these nolan
inducing factors and essentially you end
up with 300 neural aggregates with
between 4,000 and five thousand cells
per aggregate in order to form no
rosettes you concede all of these neural
aggregates into a six-well plate and
then
rosettes I'll show you what happens when
you actually take one of these neural
aggregates and put them in a 24-well
play both on laminin and we've done some
work we've see that these into fibrin as
well and and show you some of those
results just to give you an idea of what
these look like here you can see the
microloans this is after five days of
culture and you can see they form nice
and spherical neural aggregates at this
point and i called the mill aggregates
because as we found they tend to
differentiate a hundred percent into nor
lineages cells and i mentioned a few
culture these once you have all your
results or you have all your neural
aggregates if you call to them in a 6
well plates together then they begin to
formers at seven days so five days of
aggregate formation seven days post that
you start to see these rosettes which
are essentially your mini spinal cords
and you can actually select out for
these which we've we've done in some
cases as we try to get a pure population
of North engenders associated with the
central nervous system here's what
happens when you see single neural
aggregates on laminin so this isn't a 24
wall plate and it's the only inner liber
get in the well so this is when you have
300 you get neural aggregate or you get
no as that formation when you see single
nuraghe gets you just get a lot and
you'll see a lot of neurite outgrowth
that stays positive again this is for
the narrow market to you J 1 and so it's
quite interesting to see the effects of
crosstalk when you have all these
progenitor cells together we did seed
some neural aggregates into our fibrin
scaffolds and we need some optimization
trying to find what concentration of
fibrin he sells like to grow in for
reference all the mouse work was done at
a concentration of ten MiG's per mil and
fibrin scaffolds to give you sort of a
reference when you use fiber and
surgical glue that's usually up much
higher concentrations like 80 to 100
MiG's per mil and as you can see here
and they were quite this is actually a
viability assay so there the phase
contrast photos on top and then vote the
lower boxes green cells indicate by
admin cells red cells are dead cells but
again we had high level
viability and in this case with these
now aggregates we did seize the cells
going out and infiltrating our vibrant
gels we were able to quantify this and
similar to our mouse studies we saw
between eighty and ninety percent
viability and this was also similar to
levels we did this all in comparison to
growing these on on controls like I
previously showed we also did some
neuronal staining and so and as you can
see that you can start to see some of
these cells it actually differentiated
out an extended processes in the
different concentrations of fibrin gels
and we were able to some some
quantification obviously we'll need to
replicate this but what if preliminary
looks like is somewhere between the
eight mix and twelve makes camilla five
and really promote and more neuronal
differentiation or similar levels to our
laminin compared to the very lowest and
the very highest concentrations of gels
intriguingly as we actually tried to
select out for these neural rosettes and
we seeded neural rosettes as opposed to
and the neural aggregates so the neural
aggregates were done just after we're
putting in five adults five after that
five-day induction period in the neural
induction media and then they defined
and infiltrated this and so this would
be a nose that's selected after an
additional week after they've made those
results and we specifically selected out
there is oats and the sauce would made
viable when we cultured them out for for
two weeks but they didn't really ever
infiltrate the gel and so it was almost
like going at seeding these later these
more mature cells they weren't as likely
to enter the gel and wanted to remain as
an aggregate so that was quite
interesting to observe so we're
continuing to work on this and optimize
these scaffolds for our human
pluripotent stem cells and one of the
things we found is that a fiber
concentration does influence
differentiation and we need to work on
that to figure out what's optimal to get
our or maximum neuronal differentiation
this also food chain more efficiently on
2d laminate surfaces in our 3d scaffolds
but we can possibly fix this if we can
optimize out our parameters
and this issue with trying to figure out
seating time and how to get more mature
male progenitor cells to migrate into
our scalpel it's also going to be a
challenge and it's something we're
looking at is what's the optimal time to
put these cells in our gels for
transplantation so for those we might
talk i'm going to switch gears from all
of our fibrin work and talk a bit about
synthetic scaffolds and more of a drug
delivery aspects of our work so a
synthetic scaffold is usually chemically
synthesized and these scaffolds have a
lot of 20 properties and for example you
can get a larger range of mechanical
properties when you work with a
synthetic scaffold and a large range of
degradation rates so fibrin and most
other proteins and polysaccharides estas
you're really looking at at very
relatively short degradation times
you're looking at weeks maybe months if
you get some chemical cross-linking in
there was for synthetic scaffolds you
can easily get polymers or polymer
scaffolds for the last month's and this
gives you some more properties to play
with both in terms of mechanical
properties but else in terms of drug
deliveries so if you think about spinal
cord injury we were looking at a healing
time course of months so if you have a
scaffold that could deliver drugs over
this time course of months it's really
going to be advantageous compared to
five in which only lasts about two weeks
so even if you have a successful drug
delivery system if your protein
scaffolds degraded after two weeks then
that's going to max that's gonna be the
maximum time course you can deliver
drugs another thing which I'll talk a
bit about is you can tailor your
synthetic scaffolds into specific shapes
and give them different properties also
they have known chemical compositions so
you can design your chemical palmer to
have minimal immune response and also
when you work with things like proteins
that are derived from blood they have
the parent variability and sometimes you
have to worry about a lot to want
variation and in shown here in the
scaffold or two of our different drug
releasing synthetic scaffolds the first
one and our nano fibers which have
incorporated in protein drugs and lower
picture although i'm not going to talk
about today is a our group has
established micro particle technology
that releases drugs also over extended
time periods as well
but the polymer we've chosen to work
with is polycaprolactone and one of the
main reasons we've chosen to work with
this you can see in the lower corner
it's essentially a bright white plastic
is that it lasts a very long time in in
an in vivo setting and for a lot of our
neurological disorders such as spinal
cord injury or Parkinson's you want a
drug release system that's going to
release drugs over months and so that's
what we've been trying to get out with
these polycaprolactone scaffolds we make
also it's biodegradable eventually as I
mention before it's one of our synthetic
polymers it's FDA approved and a lot of
times people use this for surgical
sutures you can also fabricate into a
variety of structures as I'll show it's
quite easy to work with and it's quite
affordable as well but i'll be talking
about today's we make these scaffolds
that are made of nanofibers through
process called electrospinning which
I'll get into in a second it just rings
versatile technique it's become quite
popular in the last decade and it's
quite easy to set up and you can
fabricate these scaffolds from any sort
of polymer as long as you can dissolve
it in solvent and as you can see along
the bottom here's some of the examples
of our scaffolds and why they are
desirable so a is just a randomly
collected electrospun scaffold and be
continued actually aligned our
nanofibers so now they have
directionality and topography and see as
I have shown before we've actually spun
in protein drugs into our scaffolds as
well so they can be drunk releasing
that's obviously something we're very
interested in and indeed just show some
of our mouths induced pluripotent stem
cells that have actually been cultured
on a polycaprolactone scaffold so that's
another nice thing about these scaffolds
as they do support stem cell culture as
would be an not appropriate to choose
polymers that stem cells don't want to
interact with which you can often run
into a synthetic polymers are and
scaffolds that aren't necessarily
compatible with stem cell culture and
often need to be functionalized with
other things like proteins in order to
get them to bind so the type of
electricity will be talking about today
is called solution electrospinning and
for example for polycaprolactone you
have your polymer that needs to be
dissolved in a solvent in order to give
you a solution and that's
pretty standard for for any of these
electrospinning processes if you had to
actually include your drug you often and
can alyssa phi it in this polymer
solution or those other ways of actually
directing your polymer solution where
you have essentially an outer core layer
of polymer and an inner layer of drug as
well but for hours it's usually been a
motion based solution electrospinning to
produce our scaffolds so if you have
your polymer solution that contains your
polymer solution and any drugs you want
to include you then essentially have the
selector spinning set up which you have
a dispenser and then you have a polymer
collector which will collect your
scaffold once it spins and there's a
high charge so you're both your
dispenser and your collector highly
charged and two about two very like 110
kilovolts this causes your palm or a
solution to be drawn out and it starts
to spin and you can collect it on your
plate if you don't do anything special
about how you collect these nano fibers
on the plate they'll appear randomly
like I showed in the last slide you can
collect them on a spinning drum and it
will actually cause them to a line and
so then in that way you can start to get
some of your topography as well
depending on how you collect them I'm
not going to talk about tangos other
ways you can elect wristband but avoid
using solvents which is called mullet
roe spinning which our group is also
involved in in that case you just
directly melt the polymer and you can
direct right out what sort of topography
scaffolds you'd like so how can we
control no differentiation using these
scaffolds knowing we have these two
parameters the topography as well as
chemical cues so we did two things first
you ready to show we can produce
different typographies using our
electrospinning set up the second part
was to show we could incorporate in
small molecules into these scaffolds and
then actually get these molecules out
over the time course we desire and so
our goal is to get a multifunctional
scaffold the prison of both physical and
chemical cues and one of the reasons
this has been so difficult to do
previously is anytime you add in a
chemical cue to a solvent it affects the
properties of polymer solution and
oftentimes it makes things harder to
spend which is why if you'll recall when
we saw and the different types of
scaffolds the ones that had very nice
typography
very straight nanofibers those were spun
from pure polymer solution or as the
protein containing ones for on how
different sizes and appear to have have
different radiuses at points because of
the effect of the protein on the polymer
solution and changing its properties and
so here you can see those again in our
group we've spun both randomly oriented
nanofibers as well as when align
nanofibers and these are our blank
scaffolds this was just using pure PCL
and just trying to show that we could
get some nice typography achieved and
these are scanning electron microscopy
photos some work I had previously done
back when I was at Washington University
we had shown that if you take an orca
janitor is derived from mouse embryonic
stem cells and seed of the mummies
randomly line scaffolds the cells would
migrate out in all different directions
and you also see this a lot not just
with our synthetic scaffolds ball so
dark vibrant scaffolds the cells will
migrate out in all directions however if
you use these align scaffolds you
actually get really nice neurite
extension that moves at along these nano
fibers and the starts get a
directionality and for spinal cord
injury this could potentially be useful
if you could implement this in nvivo
setting to actually orient your neurons
to migrate down the nanofibers and give
you more directionality as opposed to
having your cells migrate out in form of
mesh over the injury site so this could
be one way to start then getting some
higher order into your tissues that are
your engineering the other aspect which
we will work yond and simultaneously
with this was trying to incorporate drug
release into these polymer scaffolds as
I mentioned before for spinal cord
injury studies if we could incorporate
the drugs into the pcl this is going to
give us a longer time course to play
with and potentially you could have
different formulations of pcl scaffolds
to release different drugs over
different times and so by having a pcl
scaffold that can release drugs over
months this is quite valuable in terms
of treating spinal cord injury release
from these scaffolds is usually based on
the diffusion characteristics and will
I'll talk about the a bit about that in
a second and how larger nanofibers are
and for these studies we used retinoic
acid is our small molecule of choice for
several reasons and
it's quite affordable we wanted to work
out our electrospinning process before
moving to more expensive proteins and
you can detect retinoic acid release
color metrically and using spectroscopy
so it's also quite easy to detect as
opposed with proteins where you need to
utilize those so some of the first work
from my group was just showing that you
could actually spend these retinoic acid
I retinoic acid into pcl and we wanted
also see we could do two different doses
so this would give us another parameter
to play with so we have our topography
the drug we're delivering and then the
concentration of the drug we're
delivering and so again you can see that
these are and other a lot of them are
straight you do see some Kirby nano
fibers that are just due to the
incorporation of these bioactive agents
into our schedules we also were able to
collect these on our spinning drum in
order to get towards alignment and so
again three different rates we were able
to get varying degrees of alignment for
our scaffolds we also went through and
we wanted to characterize these so as I
mentioned when you change the properties
of polymer solution you also change the
properties of the nano fibers that are
getting a spin-out during the process so
in other things you'll notice for both
the aligned and randomly oriented
scaffolds so if we just look at the
blanks and overall trims the line fibers
tended to be bigger which is probably a
function of being collected on that
rotating drum and and then you'll also
notice that any time we incorporated in
our retinoic acid and we've also seen
this trend although I won't show it
today for the proteins anytime you
incorporated a biologically active agent
you also tend to get thicker fibers as
well and then more and when you add in
these agents you also tend to increase
variability as well so that's sort of
summing up this whole process and what
the effects are of incorporating your
your bio active agents in and also
aligning them so essentially the war
bioactive agents and alignments can
increase your size and variability and
this is this sort of some setup any time
you add retno cals did you get an
increase in nano fiber diameter you also
get variability and in general d-line
fibers for larger than the randomly
oriented Piper's
we had some early studies and I'm just
going to show up briefly we did these
also for the randomly oriented scaffolds
we got similar results so we found that
in two weeks studies we were getting
about nine to fifteen percent of the
retinoic acid being root of it of the
total area loaded empty scaffolds be
released at two weeks so suggests we
could get release over months and at
this point we were looking at
specifically the the point two percent
scaffolds because they seemed to be the
most reproducible for both the randomly
oriented group and the align so he chose
to further characterize these as well
and I think these are the ones to
deliver and the amount of retinoic acid
would be most relevant to our studies
we've previously conducted as well and
so when we took these out 30 days again
we saw between about eight and seventeen
percent of the right now gasps of being
released at this time point and
curiously we saw that the randomly
oriented scaffolds and release more
retinoic acid by the end although that
makes sense if you think the Fed fibers
are thinner so they should have a much
higher rate of diffusion as well and it
was slower from the align scaffolds and
again there was some some variability
but in general this is going to give you
so this is a month so if you have
similar trends you should be getting
released from these scaffolds for a
couple of months hopefully at least we
went to depends and we've gone back to
working with their mouths for these
studies and we wanted to just see again
if we could quantify the viability on
all four of our scaffolds so we cultured
our mouse Android bodies these are made
using the sonic hedgehog on the retinoic
acid and pure morphine differentiation
the six-day protocol and we seeded them
on each of these scaffolds both the
blank ones and the retinoic acid
releasing ones and we are able to
quantify and the amount of viable cells
so again red cells are dead green cells
are alive and we have a device called
the inky site which is a live cell
imager which also does for us and so on
the jank allows us to quantify the mean
intensity for each of these samples and
you can see that there are high degrees
of liability for all of these on the
line scaffolds the import body
tended to become longer and migrate
again like we saw with a mouse and
Brianna stem cells they tend to migrate
along the nanofibers and sort of become
more spread out whereas on the random
scaffolds they migrate out in all
directions as well also on the retinoic
acid scaffolds they tended to have more
cells growing and this possibly can be
due to the fact or releasing bioactive
retinoic acid as well we also wanted to
see if they differentiated into neurons
when we exceeded them upon these
scaffolds and try and get it some of
that quantification and again you can
see that for the Alliance scaffolds the
cells also tended to migrate along these
nano fibers as well both in the face and
remove stain this is again for to you J
1 and and again you see cells migrate on
all directions when you have these
randomly align scaffolds as well so this
was just showing that we could get the
differentiation of these progenitors
into neurons when we had them on our
scaffolds so um conclusions from this
portion of our study as we could obtain
controlled release of retinoic acid from
both types of topography and we found
that aligned aligning the topography
contributes to variance and release and
so it's down there these process one
interesting thing a lot of times of drug
delivery systems you'll see what's
called burst release so in those drug
delivery profiles you don't see like
there you saw almost a slow steady
release normally in drug delivery
systems you'll see a large release of
drug initially over the first day or two
or three and in ours you didn't see
that's that's that's useful to know if
we're going to actually implement this
in a clinical setting the treatment of
spinal cord injury to know that we
aren't going to have this initial burst
of drugs and from our polycaprolactone
electrospun scaffolds then we've shown
that these scaffolds also support the
mouse induced pluripotent stem cell
culture and differentiation which is
closely which followers what we've
observed with our mouse embryonic stem
cell culture but it's always good to
confirm that it works with these new
cell types and now we're hoping to apply
all this technology to all of our human
induced pluripotent stem cell technology
as well
so as I mentioned at one of the next
areas we've been working on we currently
have the lease studies going on and in
this area is to use these scaffolds to
release proteins as well and so in this
case and these are actually just some
contrasting folds that we've loaded with
bovine serum albumin but we also have
currently made scaffolds that release
khalil derived neurotrophic factor and
so the proteins it becomes a little bit
more complicated because first of all
they tend to as they're bigger molecules
they tend up much larger effect on the
solution your electrospinning compared
to small molecules such as retinoic acid
also for things like wheel drive
neurotropic factor you would have to
perform Eliza's as opposed to just being
able to call metrical eat all that your
sample has been released so that's why
we first been optimizing these with
bovine serum albumin before moving on to
growth factors the other issues when you
use these solvents they often can
inhibit or actually contribute to the
loss of bioactivity for your proteins
and so that's another reason why people
often encapsulate when they're
encapsulated growth factors like nerve
growth factor or gdnf they encapsulate
with bovine serum albumin is to preserve
the activity of these proteins so then
they can release in a bioactive fashion
when you're delivering your drugs and so
it's a so that's why proteins are a bit
harder to get out releasing compared to
small molecules for these neural tissue
engineering applications so where we
eventually want to go with this and I
think we're getting closer to there is
to make a hybrid scaffold for
controlling differentiation and so
ideally as i mentioned each of these
synthetic and natural biomaterials have
properties that are really desirable so
for example five on scaffolds are really
great at promoting cell survival when
you plan to the injured spinal cord so
it's definitely important to have this
vibrant component it only lasts about
two weeks so how I picture it working in
an ambulance setting is you transplant
your cells in the fiber matrix and this
would sort of get them initially to grow
and survive and then once they've
essentially degraded the fiber matrix
will to create their own healthy
extracellular matrix to grow in but it
also be supplemented with these
nanofiber scaffolds which would be
delivering drugs over time course of
months and ideally
I'm not sure how feasible this will be
to implement in an animal study but it
would be nice if we could actually also
take advantage of that topography and
get ourselves to a line in the injured
spinal cord in a manner where you'd
actually get them oriental like they
would be found in healthy spinal cord
tissue then you can have these drug
release the struggling release that
promotes the differentiation of your
iPSCs into these neurons over the extent
of time course and so in that way when
you go in vivo into this harsh injury
site that's left by spinal cord injury
you can sort of address some of the
issues by getting the cells to
repopulate what's normally in and a
harsh injury site with their own
extracellular matrix that they secrete
as well as implementing it with drugs
such as anti-inflammatories as well as
lowering cues such as retinoic acid and
pure luck for mean as well as other
growth factors like gdnf to get
yourselves to become neurons and
integrate with the existing tissue you
have in the spinal cord and so with that
I'd like to thank everybody in my lab
especially new Mecca Dean McComb and Amy
Montgomery performed a lot of the work
you've seen here as well also I'd like
to thank all my funding sources
including the Canada Research Chair
program and in Cirque for providing
while the funding for this as well as
the Canadian foundation for innovation
and all the other agencies that have
supported my work and with that let me
know if you guys have any questions and
I can try to answer them
oh so and I have two questions till try
and answer in the two minutes we have
left yes i have set of translating I so
the first question is he thought of
translating these two injectable
scaffolds and the answer is yes fibrin
is is modulated by thrombin and calcium
competent concentration so it is
possible to make them injectable and
that's definitely consideration we have
will translate it to that form when we
actually move into doing animal studies
and when you're working in a dish it's
easier just to and essentially up as
long as you want for these scaffolds
supplies so we work with our
concentrations in that way the second
question was do any of your nana's
scaffolds cross the blood-brain barrier
and for these what we've been mainly
looking at is spinal cord injuries so in
that case it's already going to probably
be disrupted or if we're going in
post-surgery you're going to have to 2m
essentially open it back up in order to
place the scaffolds in the injury site
for other applications such as going
into the rain for other types of mill
disorders we have looked into making
injectable formulations which sort of
goes along with the first question and
in order to get around the blood-brain
barrier
you